good morning everybody and I want to
thank Speaker Pelosi senator Shaheen and
representative Allred and all of our
Senate and House Democrats who were here
with us today
now last week we learned of President
Trump and Attorney General bars decision
to change their legal position and
declare the entire Affordable Care Act
unconstitutional this is an escalation
of their earlier outrageous position
that pre-existing conditions are
unconstitutional now they want to hurt
the American people even more in two
short sentences
the Department of Justice summed up the
Trump and the Republican position health
care coverage for nearly 20 million
Americans pre-existing condition
protections and tax credits to afford
care should all be taken away with no
plan whatsoever to replace them the
potential consequences of this
politically motivated move can't be
overstated
skyrocketing costs for families massive
increases in prescription drug spending
for seniors on Medicare women charge
more because they're a woman seniors
charge more because of their age cancer
patients denied coverage and the list
the cruel list goes on and on and on
Democrats condemn in the strongest of
terms the Republican attacks against the
American people and that is why we are
here today today Senate and House
Democrats are introducing resolutions to
reverse this misguided and cruel
decision by the Trump administration's
Department of Justice all 47 Democrats
in the Senate are united in demanding
that President Trump and Attorney
General bar reverse their callous legal
assault on Americans health care
Republicans failed as you may recall
Republicans failed to pass any of their
health care plans in Congress so they're
trying to repeal health care in the
courts this reeks of desperation and
they do not have a back-up plan last
night the president tweeted that they
will come up with their plan in 2021
translation they have no health care
plan it's the same old song they've been
singing there for repeal
they have no replace President Trump
confirmed that he will hold Americans
hostage through the 2020 election when
it comes to health care
he promises reelect me and maybe you can
take a peek at my back-up plan after
that which they don't have what a ruse
what a shame what a disgrace we know
that what the Republicans health care
plan might look like gut protections for
Americans with pre-existing conditions
massive losses of coverage destabilize
insurance markets help the big fat
insurance companies the drug companies
and all their special interest wealthy
donors so when President Trump insists
he has a magic plan that we can see if
only the American people reelect him we
know is just not true the American
people will not stand for the president
playing cynical games with health care
and politically by betting with the
health of twenty thirty forty million
Americans
he is sure to lose don't let president
Trump fool you America Republicans are
not the party of health care they are
the party that wants to end your health
care we Democrats will not stop fighting
tooth and nail to protect Americans
health care today tomorrow and on in
through 2021
Pelosi good morning everyone it's an
honor to join the distinguished
Democratic leader of the United States
Senate senator Shaheen a leader on the
protecting the care of the American
people and Colin Allred from the House
of Representative freshman member who's
taken the lead on this issue from day
one in the Congress we're here to
condemn what the president did last week
the Trump administration radically
expanded its war on the Affordable Care
Act on Americans health care asking the
court to strike down every last
provision of the ACA
the distinguished leader went through
some of the concerns some bear repeating
imagine that he would say after the
Republicans misrepresented their
position on pre-existing conditions
remember during the campaign they said
all we're for the benefit of not having
pre-existing condition be a barrier to
your access to health care they said
that in spite of the fact that over and
over again they have had voted to
eliminate that benefit and now the
president is acting in a way to not only
eliminate that benefit which is so
important also to eliminate a companion
benefit that goes with a pre-existing
condition to eliminate the ban on
lifetime limits and annual limits on
people with who need health care this is
terrible being a woman no longer a
pre-existing condition under the ACA up
to 26 years of age you can be on your
parents policy lengthening the stability
and the solvency of Medicare hail care
they think Medicare should wither on the
vine that is the Republican mantra when
Medicare was passed they said it would
lead to a socialist dictatorship they do
not believe in a public role they are
anti governance so this is not an issues
fight or legislative fight it's a values
fight for our country that we value the
health
wellbeing of the American people and we
recognize that their financial stability
is related to their health stability the
the Medicaid expansion as the
distinguished chairman Lee Durr said
this isn't just about the 20 million
people who have now have access to
quality affordable health care it's
about over 150 million families who have
better care better benefits again no
lifetime limits no pre-existing
condition ban and some of the other
provisions that I mentioned better
benefits lowering the increase in cost
improving the health not just the health
care but the good health of America is
about prevention it's about nutrition
it's about so many things that perhaps
they don't understand
but what we do understand is they do not
believe in public policy that affects
the good health of the American people
and that is why we are going to have
this resolution debated on the floor
today vote it tomorrow
from day one congressman Collin already
freshman from Texas led the way House
Democrats voted to throw the full legal
weight of the Democrats in the House of
Representatives and we hope that some
Republicans will join us against the
Texas lawsuit he's from Texas but more
than 190 Republicans voted to being
fully complicit in everything that this
monstrous proposal puts forth so now
because of president Trump's actions
which are to be condemned that lawsuit
is that lawsuit is even more dangerous
than it was in January and that is why
we were bringing forth the Allred
resolution this week the American people
deserve to know exactly where their
representatives stand on the Trump
administration's vicious campaign to
take away their health care this is so
interesting because the president has
been trying to do away with the
Affordable Care Act from day one we know
that and the way it was protected was
not just by our inside maneuvering it
was because of the outside mono a
mobilization of so many groups many who
are present here today
10,000 events they had 10,000 and
alzheimer 10,000 events around the
country
the little lobbyists the patient
advocacy groups age can protect our care
all kinds of organizations and
individuals coming forth with the power
of their individual stories I wasn't
just about statistics as compelling as
they are it was about the individual
stories and the individual stories of
little children born with a pre-existing
condition whose families need everything
their they need they need the health
care but they need Medicare Medicaid as
well there are children with a
pre-existing condition the president is
saying to them you now have a lifetime
limit on the care you the insurance you
can receive saying to little children
your pre-existing condition is going to
ban you from having health care that is
affordable you can have health care but
this cost will go through the roof
that's what the president is saying to
these little children not to mention
every other age group and what he's
saying to seniors as far as Medicare and
Medicaid etc are concerned so Democrats
will fight for the people for the people
agenda for all of us was lowering health
care costs lowering the cost of
prescription drugs preserving the
pre-existing medical condition as we
increase the paycheck to increase their
financial security and have HR 1 which
is our fight against big dark money in
politics if we when we pass that as the
law of the land the American people have
confidence that we can lower their
prescription drug prices protect their
health care increase their paychecks and
again today is equal pay up day so equal
pay day so a hooray for us for a passing
under rosa DeLauro Sleater ship it will
pay for equal work they're all connected
because it's about the financial as well
as the health security of the American
people and now it is my privilege to
bring to the podium yield the podium in
front of the Supreme Court to senator
Shaheen who has been such a tremendous
lead
on this subject in the United States
Senate and in the country energy good
morning and thank you very much Speaker
Pelosi I'm honored to be here with
leader Schumer with Speaker Pelosi with
Congressman Allred and with all of our
colleagues from the House and Senate we
are here this morning to say that we
oppose the Trump administration's effort
to overturn health care for Americans
and we are going to make the case every
way we can that all Americans in this
country deserve access to affordable
health care when they need it
the Department of Justice scheme to
completely invalidate the Affordable
Care Act puts millions of Americans at
risk of being unable to afford or simply
not be able to have access to their
current health care plans this assault
on Americans health care cannot go
unanswered which is why today I'm
joining my colleagues in the Senate all
47 of the Democrats 45 Democrats to
independence to introduce a resolution
that calls on the Department of Justice
to reverse its position in the Texas v
United States lawsuit more than 20
million of our family members friends
and neighbors across the country have
gained access to health care coverage
that they need and deserve through the
Affordable Care Act already 7 million of
them have lost access to health
insurance because of the actions of this
Trump administration and if the law is
overturned those living with
pre-existing conditions stand to lose
the most children like Bodhi from
Concord a young boy who lives with
spinal muscular atrophy it's a disease
that affects his mobility and that costs
hundreds of thousands of dollars a year
and necessary medication to keep him
alive well if the Trump administration
has its way millions like Bodhi could be
denied insurance coverage because of
their disease insurers will be able to
jack up costs or even cut
coverage after medical bills reach an
arbitrary threshold repealing the ACA
and unraveling the progress that we've
made is reckless we know we need to do
things to make the law work better but
as policymakers our job is to fix laws
to work better for everyone now there
are a lot of reasons why we should work
together to fix our health care system
more than 20 million reasons and they
live in Republican and Democratic
districts throughout the country and
it's their health care that's at stake
but for that we need Republicans our
Republican colleagues to come to the
table and to defend their constituents
instead of the president ensuring the
health and safety of the American people
should transcend politics so I say this
to Senate and House Republicans you have
a choice you can sit idly by while the
president strips your constituents of
their health care or you can work with
us to protect Americans care and improve
the system now I'd like to introduce
representative Colin already from Texas
who is leading efforts on a similar
resolution in the house well good
morning and thank you
speaker Pelosi senator Sheen and Senator
Schumer for organizing this effort I am
so proud to be helping to lead this
fight we are here today to say the
United States Congress will not stand
idly by while cynical partisan interests
attack the health care of hardworking
Americans I came to Washington to get
things done and I'm proud to lead this
resolution to assure an Americans that
this Congress will not allow protections
for people with pre-existing conditions
to go back to the battle days and
they're throwing off their health care
when they get sick my home state of
Texas has the highest uninsured rate in
the country and this attack is
successful millions of Texans will have
their health care taken away no law is
perfect
which is why I'll work with anyone to
protect those with pre-existing
conditions and to lower costs across the
board for the American people this is a
personal fight for me my mother is a
breast cancer survivor and my wife Ally
and I just had a baby
both of those are pre-existing
conditions and last year the day that
the House of Representatives voted for
the AHCA to repeal the Affordable Care
Act I met a woman named Natalie Cortes
now they came to my event that day from
chemotherapy see her she had stage 4
cancer and she told me that her goal was
to fight her cancer for as long as
possible so that her two children Hugo
and Mia would know her Natalie was a
lawyer married to a law professor at SMU
in Dallas and I'm proud that her husband
Nathan who survives her joined me at the
State of the Union earlier this year
unfortunately we lost Natalie but her
fight goes on she spent her final months
while she was saying her goodbyes while
she was making her preparations talking
to her friends and neighbors posting on
social media going to events and talking
about the importance of health care and
how this shouldn't be a partisan issue
and that's why I urge my Republican
colleagues in the House and the Senate
to put politics aside and to join us in
standing up for the health care of all
Americans
[Applause]
Natalie deserves no less and now more
than ever it's time for the United
States Congress to be on the side of the
people on the very first day of this
Congress we took action to make sure the
House of Representatives would stand up
and defend the Affordable Care Act in
court and this week we will continue
that action this resolution is a good
first step but I urge my colleagues as I
said to join us in this effort and to
make sure that we continue to fight to
stabilize the health care system to
lower costs and lower the cost of
prescription drugs and they're do what
the American people sent us to do here
to do which is to deliver for them thank
you so much
[Applause]